d'acier. Selon le ministre
Bonnardel, le rapport des
ingénieurs ne s'est jamais rendu
à son bureau avant mardi.
Malgré tout, François Legault
assure que le public n'est pas
en danger. Marie-Pier Bouchard,
de l'émission Enquête.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
premier ministre du Québec
- Le pont Pierre-Laporte,
je veux rassurer tout le monde,
il est sécuritaire actuellement.
- Même s'il se fait rassurant,
le premier ministre est surpris
des révélations de l'émission
Enquête sur l'état des suspentes
du pont Pierre-Laporte.
- François Bonnardel, qui est
ministre des Transports, a
appris hier l'existence de
ce rapport. C'est quand même
surprenant, on est en train
de faire une enquête, comment ça
se fait que ce n'est pas venu
sur son bureau avant?
- Radio-Canada a recueilli
le témoignage de lanceur
d'alerte et obtenu un rapport
qui nous apprend que les câbles
verticaux qui soutiennent
le tablier du pont sont de moins
en moins résistant.
Un document de plus de 100
pages, signé par deux
ingénieurs, qui a été déposés
le 21 avril. Il recommande
le remplacement de toutes les
suspentes le plus tôt possible.
FRANÇOIS BONNARDEL,
ministreministreministre des Trc
- Moi, je trouve inacceptable
d'avoir été informé à la
dernière minute et que vous ayez
été informé avant moi.
- Le ministre des
confirme que le remplacement
de tous ces câbles va être
accéléré.
- Le ministère prévoyait
un remplacement ou
une consolidation des suspentes
des 160 d'ici les 15 prochaines
années. us assurer
une chose aujourd'hui, ça prend
moins de 15 ans pour consolider,
ou réparer, ou remplacer
spentes.
MARC-ANDRÉ MARTIN, Asso., prof.,
ingénieurs du gouvernement, Qc
- C'est un lanceur d'alerte qui
est obligé de dévoiler l'état
de l'infe, c'est
épouvantable.
- Le président du syndicat
des ingénieurs du gouvernement
craint maintenant une chasse
aux sorcières au sein du
re des transports.
- On va mettre plus d'efforts
pour essayer de trouver qui a
divulgué la vérité plutôt que
mettre des vrais... des réels
efforts pour renforcerl'expertis
expert, pas plus de travaux.
GILLES LEHOUILLIER,
maire de Lévis
- C'est la raison pour laquelle
nous on se dit : ça prend un
nouveau lien au plus sacrant.
- Rapidement, le maire de Lévis
a sauté sur l'occasion pour
remettre le sujet du 3e lien
à l'avant-plan. Alors que
le maire du Québec demande
plutôt au ministère
des transports de donner
l'heure juste.
BRUNO MARCHAND, maire de Québec
- Ça, ils ont besoin de ça.
Ils ont besoin de cette
démonstration avec des données
probantes de ce qui va être fait
et de quelle analyse on fait si
nécessaire.
- Le pont Pierre-Laporte a 52
ans, et 15 de ses 160 suspentes
ont été remplacés jusqu'à
nt.
Ici Marie-Pier Bouchard,
Radio-Canada, Qué